with all the terrible things in 2021
millions of people
feel hopeless climate change income
inequality
the pandemic more than ever people are
depressed with the state of the world
and are looking for things bigger than
themselves but many people feel they are
too smart for the ancient religions
making meaning increasingly hard to come
by after all
if you derive meaning from this world
and this world sucks
well now you suck even science the great
new savior seems to have
abandoned us in our time of need as we
discover that science itself
may have gotten us here but what if i
told you
there was a new way the greatest income
opportunity
of our era welcome potential new
recruits
to the new religion of bitcoin i
am your humble guide please do not mock
our sacred garments
the religion of bitcoin first started in
2009
when satoshi oops wrong slide when
satoshi
came from on high and delivered us our
sacred text
the white paper the white paper is
currently the best-selling
religious text of all time and you can
pick it up
at your local kinkos today i will be
giving you
a tour of all the things the bitcoin can
offer you
[Music]
the first thing you must know is that
the bitcoin
is money if money wasn't so stupid
let me explain something to you right
now okay here's a ten dollar bill
this is garbage this is garbage you're
people in south africa
you have your ran it's all going to zero
against bitcoin
do you know that it's a criminal offense
to tear up
uh oh trouble here we have a classic
scene
of when a no coiner confronts bitcoin's
high priest
max keiser let's see how he reacts
max do you know that it's a criminal
offense to tear up
do you know that with the bitcoin i have
i can buy any freaking senator or
congressman i want
i make the laws he who has the bitcoin
makes the laws rand
this is correct he who has the bitcoin
makes the laws
so it is written i my understanding is
that you were visited by the ghost of
satoshi
yeah satoshi speaking through all of
her or his disciples on youtube your
laser eyes are pointed right at my brain
right now
ah yes you might think it is strange to
have laser eyes
but in bitcoin all things are possible
the bitcoin literally makes everything
better bitcoin fixes everything your
jewelry will be
twice as good half as expensive real
estate your house will be twice as big
half as expensive
debt you will be able to buy an annuity
that yields eight percent interest with
no risk
and and if you wish me to make a
political statement the political
statement would be
it fixes governments because as it fixes
everything else
governments act rationally now i know
your brain must be reeling at all the
incredible things
the bitcoin can do for you but let us
not forget
the most important part the bitcoin
is alive it's very interesting um
you you seem to allude to or refer to
bitcoin as something of a new life form
the reason i bring this up is because
the way it acts
seems like it's alive what are your
thoughts on this a crypto
is a living creature we've we've
released life in cyberspace
once you've released the dna of the of
the bitcoin
you just have to let it fester
everywhere in the world and let it be
it quite amazing yes i haven't even
mentioned
the best part the bitcoin is not only
alive
it is also a life force bitcoin is
conservation of energy you can store
your life force
using this knowledge you can be
immortalized as your bitcoin
your body may die but your life will
live forever
on the blockchain i put my my monetary
energy my life force into
it and then i let it i let it live
for the next thousand years and it's
okay
just to be alive for a thousand years
it's okay to be
you know what's wrong with being rich
forever
right i mean now that you know
all the great things to expect from
joining the bitcoin the question is
will you join the bitcoin and become one
of the many
cyber hornets on your twitter the lead
tweet is
the mentions of cyber hornets i refer to
everybody on
everybody on twitter and everybody in
the community that's that's uh
educating the world and defending
bitcoin but i was also thinking about
every bitcoin miner
running a bitcoin mining rig everywhere
on earth and they're fighting for the
network
and i was thinking about everybody
running a node
and i think a note is like an altar to
satoshi
in your house in conclusion do not view
the bitcoin as one of many mere
cryptocurrencies
that is what the heretics said instead
you must answer the call as many have
satoshi into my heart